and the Spurs off and running when
banana fill in the lane
goes Twain
and smoke the slam
and that's how he changes the equation
Doris oh my goodness the length is gonna
take people by surprise how about that
passing up his teammate Dominic Barlow
his handle already open floor handle how
about this room seven foot three little
for him but boy The Presence at The Rim
my goodness Miller with a little Rim
pressure had it potentially partially
blocked from across the room he
swallowed one attempt up at The Rim
Early in this quarter here's Miller the
number two pick laces his second three
ball of the night and posts up against
Miller got a little one Miller tried to
Big Boy him and body them
peeled them clean and they turned them
over
Bailey on the break it's kind of
striking to see it is but he's we've
seen him make a number of clean switches
already and look at that he hijacked
that one
but you were talking about this his
ability to Garden the perimeter he said
it multiple clean switches and how many
here they are
Wendy got caught up on the screen died
on the screen that time Doris
gonna be interesting to watch his screen
navigation if he's guarding perimeter
players
got foul that time
he's come
[Music]
here's Miller
wemby switches on to him moving his feet
Miller defers to book Knight
and a good decision that time off the
Euroleague MVP accepting a deal oh
Miller wow nice double move Victor on
his knees
[Applause]
he crossed them twice so the first cross
little step back cross second cross you
see Victor took a little contact to the
neck a little confused by the call nice
double move by Mr Miller
I know pop has been around the globe
somewhere usually he goes to those as
wonderfully exotic places in the
summertime Miller fire some deep and
drills another three
with 29 seconds to go Miller up into him
couldn't finish through the count